madre e mio padre io da bambino quando
quella signora mi preparava da mangiare
e io ero capriccioso come tutti i
bambini e mi ricordo la cosa che amavo
di più da piccolino era la la ricotta mi
faceva impazzire questa ricotta un po
perché mio nonno abbondanza francesca è
stato uno dei pionieri del canestrato di
moliterno ed era un grande casaro e ci
faceva una ricotta che ci faceva
impazzire
l'unica cosa che era una ricotta carica
molto forte tutto pecora m mi puzza
vasta ricotta però nel tempo iniziato ad
apprezzarla e quindi ho provato così
negli anni dice perché non facciamo un
piatto con con la ricotta
beh signori cari è venuto fuori un
piatto che negli anni sta riscontrando
un successo veramente veramente forte
premiato anche alla fiera internazionale
della pasta a bologna
vi dico velocemente gli ingredienti è
composto da ricotta fonduta di
caciocavallo podolico pistacchio di
stigliano che non tutti conosceranno che
insomma il pistacchio sta anche in
basilicata conoscono tutti il pistacchio
di bronte con dei funghi porcini e vi
posso garantire che il risultato è
veramente occhio questa ecco la ricotta
il fuscello che mio nonno preparava in
vimini e io da piccolino mia mi accaniva
a guardarlo quando lui preparava
preparava il fuscello e poi ci mettevano
la ricotta emanava un odore quindi
insomma siamo abituati dei sapori veri
sapori dell'infanzia
questa è la famosa ricotta che abbiamo
messo nella nostra ricetta
ecco i nostri piatti pian piano come
diceva prima ha iniziato ad essere
apprezzata anche da persone del mondo
dello spettacolo dello sport della
politica
uno di questi è monica bellucci dove
negli anni addietro presente qui a
matera per fare per girare un film era
nostra ospite spesso veniva la sera ci
chiamava un episodio bello era quello
quando mi chiamò a casa di sera sono la
signora bellucci posso prenotare un
tavolo e dico perso babbo natale ho
chiuso il telefono mi richiama la
signore della bari ci guarda che l'ha
cercata la signora bellucci di carmela
poi ripassare le mi fa ma perché non ci
crede
beh non è che tutti i giorni monica
bellucci di chiama a casa per per
prenotarvi insomma io guardavo mia
moglie dice ma capita a me non contento
negli anni addietro arriva questo
signore qua una sera 10 io voglio
mangiare bene qua perché l'amica mia mi
ha consigliato di venire qua
monica bellucci quindi cosa vuol dire il
passaggio e dire non il turista il
turista per caso non esiste il turista
va trattato che sia la star che siano
turisti casuale va trattato bene ma
essere deve essere accolto come se fosse
come se dietro di lui arrivata tanta
gente perché il passaparola esiste
questo è un altro dei personaggi in cui
io veramente
ricordo con piacere fu un episodio che
mi ha mi ha travisato sconvolto e una
persona che io francamente non conoscevo
perché non me lo ricordo stava li
mangiava con la sua compagna in un altro
tavolo in fondo si trovava federico
amendola con stefano fresi attore che
sono tra l'altro i cognati e stavano
festeggiando il compleanno
salendo alla cassa per pagare il conto
stefano fresi si ferma guarda
christopher lloyd e mi fame ma lo sai
chi è quelli no non lo so come non lo
sai lui si avvicina e gli chiede che ci
facciamo una foto l'attore chiede
all'attore ci facciamo una foto dietro
arriva federico amendola e dice io sono
il figlio di ferruccia meno questo si
alza piangendo l'abbraccia perché
ferruccia mento è stato doppiato in uno
dei suoi film più famosi e quindi
america a roma matera ci sono questi
incontri casuali veramente che fa mi
hanno lasciato veramente interdetto
questo e altro personaggio con cui avuto
il piacere di fare una serata insieme e
ricordo l'episodio era un lunedì
eravamo a casa il compleanno di mia
moglie è qui presente ai suoi 40 anni
adesso un po più anziana e l il signore
mi chiamano mia guarda che stasera preso
al cobo cenare adatto ristoranti guarda
che io stasera sono chiuso chiama come
dobbiamo fare anche perché vuol parlare
di cucina in occasione del matrimonio
della della figlia e al compleanno di
mia moglie le orecchiette con il
cardoncello classici ragù fresco torta
fresca ma che vogliamo di più preparo
tutto chiedo la disponibilità a un mio
collega di avere la cucina a mia
disposizione l'unica raccomandarci porta
i lampascioni perché
divoratori di lampascioni mar a comprare
un chilo di lampascioni con la salsiccia
fritta al momento tutto bello veloce lui
si divora un chilo di lampascioni alla
fine della cena mi presenta il carbone
vegetale mi invita a prenderlo ma guarda
io non ne vuoi nuova ti fa digerire ma
non ho mangiato in un bacione mangia
mangia lo prenda lei perché io non ho
bisogno e questo è un altro episodio che
io ricordo con con grande affetto
ecco questo non può i nostri piatti
nostre ricette quello che il messaggio
mio io mi giro a volte di coppa sono io
non sono io visto insomma ogni tanto
bisogna girarsi indietro e vedere da
dove partì per ogni tanto guardarsi
avanti dove quello che poi ancora puoi
fare c'è sicuramente da fare e si può
crescere un messaggio per i giovani dove
dico l'eccellenza si può fare con sul
proprio territorio oggi bisogno di
evadere di andare chissà dove abbiamo
dei posti fantastici io penso che c'è
spazio per tutta la previsione di 2019
ci arriverà tanta gente tanti ragazzi
possono veramente investire il proprio
denaro e il proprio tempo nel nostro
territorio avendo portandosi con se
degli elementi indispensabili amore e
passione per quello che si fa grazie